حسنًا، لدينا بعض الأخبار العاجلة من
إسرائيل: أصيب خمسة أشخاص في
حادث دهس بسيارة تصفه الشرطة الآن بأنه
هجوم إرهابي، وقع بالقرب من
سوق شعبي في وسط القدس.
هدف سي إن إن المخيف ينضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة من
القدس منذ آخر لحظة
أم التطورات، وبما أن تقاريرهم عن ما
لا يقل عن سبع سيارات إسعاف في مكان الحادث،
ما الذي يمكنك أن تخبرنا به
إيلين أكثر من ذلك بما نسمعه من
الشرطة الإسرائيلية ورؤساء الوزراء الإسرائيليين، فهم
يصفون هذا بأنه هجوم إرهابي،
والآن حدث هذا عند التقاطع
خلفي  لقد قامت الشرطة بالفعل
بنقل السيارة التي يقولون إنها استخدمت في
هذا الهجوم وقامت بتطهير
مكان الحادث بالكامل، وهذا شيء
تفعله السلطات الإسرائيلية غالبًا هو إخلاء
مكان الحادث وإعادة الحياة إلى طبيعتها في
أسرع وقت ممكن، ولكن مما نفهمه عنه
قبل ساعتين،
صدمت سيارة مشاة عند عبور هذا
التقاطع، كنا بجوار
سوق ماتين، وهو أحد
الأسواق الأكثر شعبية في القدس، ليس فقط
للسكان المحليين ولكن للسياح على حد سواء، وكان
من المحتمل أن يكون هذا وقتًا مزدحمًا للغاية مما
نفهمه على الأقل.  أصيب خمسة أشخاص
صدمتهم السيارة
أحدهم أصيب بجروح خطيرة وتم
نقلهم جميعا إلى المستشفى في
ظروف متفاوتة وتقول الشرطة الإسرائيلية
إن مدنيا تصادف أنه
مسلح في مكان الحادث أطلق النار على
السائق وقتله.  ومع ذلك، لا نعرف من
السلطات أي شيء عن هوية
السائق أو من أين أتى هذا الشخص
أو عمره ولكن ما
نعرفه هو أن الشرطة الإسرائيلية ورئيس
الوزراء يصفان هذا بأنه
هجوم إرهابي الآن،
ولم يكن رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو في الواقع كذلك.  بعيدًا
عن هنا عندما حدث هذا في حفل
تأبين للجنود الإسرائيليين
لأنه بدءًا من الليلة وغدًا هو
يوم الذكرى هنا في إسرائيل وقال ما
يلي ووصفه بأنه
هجوم إرهابي وقال إن هذا يذكرنا
بأرض إسرائيل والدولة  إسرائيل
مطلوبة من خلال العديد من التجارب
والمحن عندما وصلنا إلى مكان الحادث
رأينا العديد من سيارات الإسعاف ورأينا أيضًا
السيارة التي يُزعم أنها مستخدمة ورأينا أن
بها نافذتين على الأقل، واحدة من
نوافذها الجانبية ونافذة خلفية تم إطلاق النار عليها
بالكامل و  بل إننا في الواقع
رأينا جثة ما يبدو
أنه السائق وقد قامت
السلطات بتغطيتها ونقلها إلى
سيارة إسعاف كما كنا ننشر التقارير
منذ عدة أشهر، وكانت هذه
فترة متوترة للغاية خاصة هنا في
القدس في  الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ومن
الواضح أن الوضع والتوتر
والعنف المشتعل أه
لا يبدو أنه ينحسر لن يبدو أنه
ينحسر في أي وقت قريب